there are some surprisingly healthy
parts of foods that we're just simply
not eating so let's take a look at the
parts of foods that you may have been
throwing away and not eating
unnecessarily and stick around to the
end of the video to see one food that
you should never eat
strawberries are one of my favorite
foods but as it turns out there's a
whole lot of health benefits you can
miss by avoiding the stems throw the
entire berry into your smoothie as the
stems are rich in disease-fighting
polyphenols and minerals they also
contain tannins that have low ph levels
and can actually help with digestion
zest doesn't just mean great enthusiasm
and energy but it's also the outer
covering of citrus fruit and happens to
be rich in terpenes that actually give
our bodies some protection from cancer
cells and aging from oxidation and it's
not just the peel but the pith the white
part around the flesh it contains
hesperidin a phytonutrient that has been
shown to lower blood cholesterol reduce
blood pressure and decrease inflammation
outermost part of onions no the onion
won't suck toxins out of your feet give
me the claims hit me with them it will
clean your blood god why am i so angry
but you can boost nutrition of your soup
stews and rice using onion skins they're
rich in quercetin a flavonoid that has
anti-inflammatory anti-cancer
anti-allergy exercise improvement grain
protective properties just to name a few
do aim for the red over yellow onions to
get more of that quercetin boost
praised by the liver king himself liver
is known as nature's multivitamin as
it's one of the most nutrient dense
foods it's incredibly high in vitamin a
in the form of retinol which is the
already active form it's a great low
calorie high protein food but again make
sure you're watching your saturated fat
and cholesterol intake
broccoli and cauliflower stalks fun fact
did you know broccoli's actually a
flower
it's easy to look and think that the
green leaves are the only nutritious
part of the veggie but in reality the
stems contain healthy amounts of
antioxidants and fiber just like the
leaves the sulforaphane found in the
stems and leaves actually has potential
as a cancer fighting compound
watermelon is more than the perfect
summertime snack because while the
bright red center is delicious the rinds
are useful as well pickled watermelon
rinds are filled with citrulline an
amino acid that helps relax and dilate
arteries which can be good for your
blood pressure workouts and even sex and
it has more fiber and potassium than the
actual inside of the watermelon
eat your heart out might not just be an
old saying after all as beef heart has a
similar texture and a taste to a fine
steak yet it's inexpensive probably
because folks are hesitant to eat it but
it's actually a lean piece of meat with
a low saturated fat content in
comparison to other meats it is
considered a high cholesterol food so be
wary
carrot tops no i'm not talking about him
i'm talking about them remember the
orange part is actually the root of the
vegetable and the green leafy portion
which can be tossed in a salad added to
a salsa or a hummus have six times the
vitamin a as compared to the orange part
pineapple cores might sound kind of
off-putting but hear me out here the
entire pineapple core included is a
solid source of bromoline a
protein-digesting enzyme that has shown
to have incredible medical potential
from anti-inflammatory effects to
helping with fungal and bacterial
infections it is a little less sweet and
firmer but if eaten raw it still packs
the same nutritious punch as the rest of
the pineapple flesh
there's nothing tongue-in-cheek about
tongue or veal tongue anyway while it
may have a high cholesterol content it
is rich in zinc iron and vitamin b12
both iron and vitamin b12 help replenish
nutrients that are low when you're
anemic while zinc is an important
nutrient to keep your immune system in
tip-top shape especially during a
pandemic
turns out banana peels are useful for
more than just mario kart
eating a banana whole seems rather
untasty but the peel does become thinner
and sweeter as it ripens so maybe you
can wait a few days for the banana peel
to develop some spots bananas are known
for their high potassium content with a
fruit averaging about 400 milligrams the
peel contains an additional almost 80
milligrams of potassium plus plenty of
filling fiber banana bread actually
became such a huge hit during the
pandemic and a simple way to start using
those peels is just to throw them into
the banana bread for a boost of fiber
care about your eyesight then you're
going to want to hear this beet greens
contain two phytonutrients lutein and
zeaxanthin which have been shown to
protect against age-related eye problems
one study actually found that people who
ate foods rich in them were half as
likely to get cataracts if you're
chopping the leaves from this veggie
then you're tossing away more iron per
serving than spinach
cucumber peels are yummy healthy and
worth their weight in gold okay maybe
not that last part but the first two are
true sadly when you peel a cucumber
you're lowering the vitamin k content by
about 56 than if you were to eat it
whole and vitamin k supports bone health
and blood clotting just be sure to wash
it well to remove the wax coating that's
often applied to prevent bruising during
transport and if possible aim for the
organic sort to reduce possible
pesticide contamination
full kiwis including the kiwi skin have
become one of my go-to late-night snacks
do you scoop out the inside with the
spoon well you're missing out you can
triple the fiber intake when you eat the
entire kiwi just make sure that you wash
it well and possibly go for the organic
kind to cut down on possible pesticide
exposure while it might make you sick to
your stomach to think about an animal
stomach shouldn't tripe refers to the
edible muscle walls of the stomachs of
animals like cows buffalo and sheep who
have multiple compartments in their
stomachs tripe is low in calories yet
rich in protein vitamin b12 and the
minerals zinc and selenium
the one food that you should never eat
although if you swallow one hole i guess
it's not that big of a deal cherry pits
inside of them if they are crushed there
is a compound known as prussic acid
which is essentially cyanide so do not
chew on cherry pits
spit them out thank you why are people's
hands always cold i answer that question
and so many more on the streets in la
watch this cause i miss human
interaction click there as always stay
happy and healthy i'll see you in this
video see it click it watch people make
fun of me they do why